[Musik]
diese woche habe ich mit karo und daniel
von glasperlenspiel gesprochen und
wollte wissen wie lange gibt es die
beiden eigentlich schon als band so glas
verein für gibt es jetzt 2020 wobei wir
glaube ich das ja auch streichen können
also weiß ich nicht gezählt
dieses jahr sind zehn jahren 2000 2001
gegründet als gar kein spiel und weil
ich hab' ich habe also unsere erste
single veröffentlicht haben das ist ja
quasi die geburtsstunde von wie aspirin
spiel gewesen
auch privat sind die beiden ein paar
aber wie lange schon seit 13 jahren ja
außerdem haben sie von ihrem ersten date
erzählt bei butlers basbug war das ja
und minder in der warschauer schaar in
berlin ja ja so lustigen aber es war
wunderschön aber es war auch einfach
sehr spontan also guckt man sich
eigentlich ins handy wenn man schon so
lange zusammen ist schon sehr neugierig
ist schon sehr also sowohl auf wenn sie
mal kurze nachricht so von irgendwie
etwas hat er geschrieben und dann ließ
sie durch und dann geht es zurück und
dann wird mal so komplett durch das wird
wird die schon gemacht das thema
hochzeit ist bei den beiden allerdings
ein bisschen schwierig ganzheitlich wenn
es irgendwie waren sie ein bisschen
umgekehrt ich weiß nicht ich bin ich bin
beim thema ehe ich bin ich finde dieses
konstrukt einfach sein weil keine ahnung
jedes zweite oder dritte jedes zweite
kind scheidungskind man weiß ich auch
und nicht jeder hat dann trauma davon
zum glück und
ich bin einfach so wer zum thema ehe
geht also ein bisschen braucht braucht
man nicht wir sind irgendwie glücklich
so zusammen und wenn es ums thema
heiraten geht denke ich mir so auch wir
können doch auch unverheiratet glücklich
sein und wie schlimm werde es wenn man
antrag kriegen würde zum beispiel auf
der bühne oder so ich glaube es würde
aber nie unfair das hatten sie auch der
wie nora ich habe das gesehen dass sie
mir nur so ich finde das jeweils macht
da denken ja dann ist vorbei einfach
offiziell offiziell sag ich jetzt hier
und jetzt wenn du das machen würdest
dann wäre alles und wie sieht es mit der
familienplanung aus ich finde kinder
wundervoll ganz ganz toll und aber
kannst mir jetzt gerade noch nicht so
vorstellen und man muss ja auch immer
daran denken so ist ja auch totaler
segen wenn dann auch alles gut geht und
klappt man überhaupt die möglichkeit hat
kinder zu bekommen
deswegen werde ich jetzt nicht so sagen
okay ich werde jetzt nur glücklich wenn
ich jetzt genau in zwei jahren schwanger
werde und mein kind bekommen möchte so
ein bisschen auf mich zukommen da sind
jetzt gerade weiß ich einfach dass ich
momentan noch keins möchte aber wie
gesagt ich finde kinder ganz toll und
hätte gerne auf jeden fall eins und ich
glaube da sind wir auch uns auch einig
dass wir für firma irgendwann end haben
möchten oder zwei oder vier oder fünf
aber jetzt gerade noch rein und wir sind
auch tatsächlich gar nicht so wir haben
sich den zehnjahresplan also hatten wir
noch nie so und wir sind eher wir lassen
uns auf uns zukommen und wie kann man
sagt wir sind gerade einfach noch so
irgendwie wir haben halt bock irgendwie
noch unterwegs zu sein und musik zu
machen und irgendwie ja so dass es
gerade zu genießen was wir haben und ja
aber wie gesagt das kann sich auch
spontan an ändern aber jetzt gerade ist
es noch so dass wir da irgendwie den
fokus darauf liegen
[Musik]